- [Woman] Buzz Feed, here.
- [Kevin] Buzz Feed.
- [Woman] Loving.
- [Kevin] Nice to see you guys.
- [Man] How are you?
- [Woman] So nice to see you.
- [Woman] How's everything going, today?
Are you celebrating already?
- Oh, yeah. We've been drinking
since we got in the car.
- Yeah, hours ago.
- Wait, wait. Is this
going to be last year
at the Oscars where they asked
really ridiculous questions?
- No, no. We're taking it
very seriously this year.
So, we have a breathalyzer on the carpet.
BuzzFeed presents
Breathalyzing Celebrities
at The Golden Globes
- [Kevin] You put your
lips together and blow.
- [Man] Sure. What's your favorite drink?
- [Kate] Tequila!
- [Kevin] Tequila, yeah.
- [Kate] We just had some.
- [Woman] So, who wants to go first?
All right, ready?
- [Man] It's .043.
- [Kate] What does that mean?
- [Man] You're halfway to
the legal driving limit.
- Oh, I'm halfway!
- So we've been breathalyzing people
who have been having fun.
Just to make sure they're having
an appropriate amount of fun.
- I'll prove it to you.
- [Jeff] You can do it.
- [Woman] All right.
- [Woman] Let's prove, let's have--
- A urine test, I'll do
a urine test if you want.
- [Man] When it gets to zero,
breath until it clicks.
You got this.
- [Woman] That's the
sound of Jeff Goldblum--
- It clicked. I heard it click.
Perfect, .000.
- All right, straight.
I'm on the natch, straight and narrow.
- You got this you're a natural.
- [Woman] Yes, it goes.
- [Man] Perfect.
- [Man] .000.
- [Woman] You weren't lying.
- Not a liar.
- I'm going to drop your mic.
- [Man] Caught it!
- [Woman] That was nice!
- [Woman] Have you been
having fun already?
- We had a little bit.
We had two drams of very nice whiskey
in the car, on the way over.
- It's a whiskey advent calendar.
So it's amazing.
- Yeah.
We have a whiskey advent calendar.
Thank you, Patton Oswalt.
- As Jesus warrants!
- As Jesus warrants that's what I thought.
- Yeah, that's exactly right.
- [Woman] Breath, breath.
Let's do it, let's do it, let's do it!
Okay!
- [Man] .009!
- Yes!
You know, I'm not trying to be
all color, but this type of blowing
is not reminiscent.
It's not indicative of--
- [Man] .017!
- [TJ] No!
- [Woman] .017!
- [TJ] Wait, but I'm cool too!
- Just remember, I'm cool too.
- I'm a whiskey drinker.
- [Man] Yup.
- And I saw some Jameson coming out there.
- I was like, why'd you think
I made a b-line over here?
- That Jameson can be yours,
but we have a game.
- Let's play it.
- [Woman] All right.
- [Woman] Let it out real nice.
- [Man] Just blow it steady, straight.
- He's familiar with
the breathalyzer. Ready?
Good. We got it.
Let's see if you're--
- What do you guess it is?
- Zero. I haven't been drinking.
- He's right! He's actually right!
- Hang on.
I could smell it. Did you open this?
- I opened this...
You're smelling my breath.
- Can you guys please get breathalyzed?
- Are you looking to maybe
grab a drink before you head in there?
- I love a little drink.
- Yeah. What if we offered you a--
- [Woman] Jameson, you want some Jameson?
- Oh that's too dangerous.
- Well, Jameson. That's me.
- [Woman] Jameson and some vodka.
- Does it say J. (mumbles)
- [Woman] Oh!
- [JK] on there?
It's just basically an alcohol commercial?
- Ain't no party like a BuzzFeed party
'cause a BuzzFeed party don't stop!
- It never stops.
- Cheers!
- Cheers, guys!
- For the ladies and for the fellows.
BuzzFeed!
You guys are going to
be the coolest website
in the United States.
- I agree.
- [Woman] Here's some tequila.
- [Ricky] That's really dangerous.
- [Woman] Some vodka?
- [Ricky] They're all dangerous spirits.
- [Man] You don't have
to drink the whole thing.
- [Ricky] They're all the work
of the devil. Those drinks!
Give me a wholesome beer.
- [Woman] Matthew! Does he want
some Jameson for inside?
Doesn't want
- [Man] Almost.
- [Woman] any Jameson for inside.